we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started we are finally
down
to the last hours fewer than 24 hours
left in donald trump's reign of terror
depending on
when you listen to this and when you
watch today's show and
somehow as we really get ourselves ready
for a new administration a new president
a new start
hopefully turning uh uh into
experiencing an inflection point when it
comes to coronavirus and and starting to
go in a better direction
we still are seeing these last
gasps of desperation from donald trump
to see if maybe somehow he could do
something to open the window even
slightly to remaining in power and now
abandoned by so many having
conceded and i use that term very
narrowly
conceded that there will be a transition
that there will be a new administration
donald trump over the weekend had my
pillow
ceo mike lindell at the white house
who was spotted holding notes
where zoomed in uh photos showed
martial law and other of these
hair-brained ideas
and we're going to look at the details
and of course as rolling stone and
others have been reporting
we know trump is out of options we know
that we are mere hours
from donald trump leaving the office of
the presidency in shame
having lost the house for republicans in
2018
having lost the senate for republicans
in 2020 and having made himself a
one-term president
and in so doing led to one of the
biggest global failures on coronavirus
the court challenges didn't work uh
pressuring republican politicians to try
to do weird things on january 6 didn't
work
focusing on the december 14th electoral
vote counts none of it worked
but trump had my
pillow uh guy mike lindell
at the white house seen entering on
friday
whose notes discussed martial law
and mike lindell although i'm not going
to play any of these agit trash
interviews that he's been doing
including from his private jet
insisting that there are still ways
there is still a path forward somehow
it appears as though as recently as 48
hours ago
donald trump was still exploring options
and still listening to people who had
these ideas
about martial law mike lindell's notes
also said insurrection act now
as a result of the assault something
something
martial law if necessary
so that is mike lindell's idea
for donald trump now importantly why is
a pillow manufacturer who believes trump
is a gift from god
uh advising a president of the united
states well the answer is in the
question
because he believes trump is a gift from
god
and these are exactly the types of
people that donald trump puts around him
he doesn't put an infectious disease
expert around him to manage a pandemic
he puts a neuroradiologist around him to
manage a pandemic
who happens to have a view favorable to
that of donald trump
and really i mean listen i don't know
about every country
but it seems that it is unique to the
united states
that a guy who sells pillows on late
night right wing media
would become a close advisor to a
president particularly in that
president's final desperate shameful
days
in office during a global cr uh a global
crisis uh the likes of which we haven't
seen for a hundred years the coronavirus
pandemic so
i received you know a ton of comments
about this story
about how terrible the my pillow pillows
are now i can't speak to that i've never
bought one of them i never would
but the important part is not about the
pillows
it's why is the pillow guy meeting with
the president of the united states to
offer advice
and in particular with a document that
says martial law
written on it but it all tracks if you
call scott atlas to help you run
infectious disease why not call a pillow
guy
right if you want or believe jared
kushner is going to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
in four years
then it tracks that you would call a
pillow guy to advise you as to how to
try to stay in power despite having lost
an election so
it's all embarrassing it's all pathetic
there are already discussions of
you know is this beyond what should be
pardoned
by joe biden in the style of gerald ford
pardoning richard nixon
i'm going to address that uh over the
next day
i'll preview my position the answer is
absolutely not there is
no way under no circumstances
should joe biden even consider a
preemptive pardon of donald trump
now there's not a sign yet that joe
biden plans to do that
but there are more and more people some
on the right some on the left some
nonpartisan
uh who are saying for the unity of the
country joe biden should look at
pardoning donald trump because it'll put
an end to this stuff
no this stuff ends in 24 hours anyway
uh and i believe it would be a grave
mistake to pardon donald trump but i
will get to that i don't want to get
ahead of myself
before we get to joe biden being in a
position to pardon anybody
we have to get through tomorrow's
inauguration and i want to talk about
the horrible things going on there
um it it almost feels surreal that i am
telling you this today because
i think many of us at least would like
to believe
that this is not the type of thing that
would be possible in the united states
but it is possible we would be naive to
think it's not possible
and that's why the fbi has started
vetting the national guard troops who
are in washington dc
to protect the city to protect the
capital to protect the white house
uh in advance of enduring joe biden's
inauguration and the reason the fbi is
vetting national guard troops
is that there are fear of insider trump
loyalists
who may even assist in or participate
in an attack tomorrow inauguration day
uh i'm almost at a loss for words
but this should not come as a total
surprise because two weeks ago i told
you
that joe biden's entire secret service
team
is being replaced rather than the
typical some trump secret service people
carry over
and some people retire and then they
bring in some new people which would be
the standard thing because of concerns
about
trump loyalists in secret service joe
biden
is getting an all-new team including
some agents from the obama era that
worked with biden
in his capacity as vice president as
well as new agents
not believed to be trump loyalists so we
knew that
a couple of weeks ago and now as you
know because of the trump riots on
january 6th
national guard troops have been called
to washington dc and they've been
patrolling the streets and street
corners of washington dc for a week now
if you look at images of it it looks
dystopian
it looks like things we would imagine
only happen in other countries but
they're happening right here in the
united states
but it is not quite so simple defense
officials
and the fbi are worried about an insider
attack
or threat from these very service
members involved in securing
joe biden's inauguration and this has
led the fbi
to start vetting all 25 000 national
guard troops
coming to washington dc or already in
washington dc for this event
now imagine what it takes to vet 25
000 troops to figure out might this be a
trump loyalist has this person been
visiting certain websites on the
internet
coordinating with certain people on the
internet and unfortunately
that degree of vetting is not going to
be possible uh what it is what it is
going to include
uh is some more automated processes for
looking through folks
maybe more detailed looks at people from
certain areas or people
um with certain characteristics i don't
even know how you'd vet 25
000 people and they're expected to be
doing the vetting all the way
up to tomorrow's inauguration and this
is a situation where
i mean listen the fbi will run
everybody's names through databases
they'll see if any of the names appear
on watch lists already
maintained to see if there's something
alarming that comes up
um if there have been names of the
troops that have been associated with
prior investigations
or terrorism related concerns but the
deep vetting that would be done like for
example for people who will be
close to joe biden in a secret service
capacity you just can't do that with 25
000 national guard troops
uh coming to washington dc on relatively
short notice but the fact that this is
even being done
is of course horrifying and very very
scary
and i i hate to say this i don't want to
make this all negative
because we are removing trump that's a
good thing and hopefully getting a fresh
start on a lot of these issues that that
we failed on as a country over the last
four years
but this is an issue radicalization of
law enforcement and military
that's been studied for a long time the
brennan center for justice has a report
called hidden in plain sight
racism white supremacy and far-right
militancy in law enforcement now we've
known for a long time that law
enforcement
tends to be more conservative than the
population at large
law enforcement tends to vote quite a
bit more for republicans rather than
democrats
the military is not historically made up
of at the sort of lower levels
uh particularly progressive individuals
although in 2020 joe biden did see more
support from within the military
than democratic presidents have seen for
a long time
but this issue of militancy and white
supremacy and racism within law
enforcement
has been studied for a long time by the
brennan center for justice
and um it is important to understand
that it is a widely known
issue and that while of course
mo i've said before this is not an
anti-cop
show or an anti-military show in terms
of the
individuals i continue to believe and
this is based on both everything i've
read
empirically and my personal experience
most police officers become police
officers for the right reasons
most people who join the military join
the military not
to go out and kill people in cold blood
or
or they they do join for what they see
as
doing something good for their community
or their country the unfortunate reality
is that law enforcement and the military
also attract
uh disproportionately culturally
conservative people
disproportionately folks motivated more
by fear and and possibly anger
disproportionately more people to
and i hate to say it um be sympathetic
to the ideas of far-right militancy now
that doesn't mean that
it's the majority it's not but relative
to the population
they are over represented and so that's
something that has to be
dealt with law enforcement and the
military have have tried different ideas
uh and so far it has not worked
particularly well and it remains a quote
persistent threat
according to the fbi um so
the point here is it shouldn't be a
surprise that this
is a concern even including the national
guard troops that will be
supposedly securing washington dc for
the inauguration of joe biden
i'm hopeful but unsure if this late
stage vetting that the fbi is doing
will be enough but my hope is
that even if some individuals slip
through
who are sympathetic to some of the goals
of the rioters
and would-be rioters that they will be
so few and far between
among the 25 000 national guard troops
that it will not really lead to an
opportunity for anybody to do anything
that even resembles what we saw on
january 6th
that's my hope and i hope it doesn't end
up being
a naive hope but we will be watching it
as we will
be covering joe biden's inauguration
tomorrow and i hope you will join me we
will be live
on youtube twitch and facebook
starting at 11 a.m eastern time 8 a.m
pacific time we will start an hour
before we will see the gathering in
washington dc
the swearing-in of joe biden as
president the swearing-in of kamala
harris as vice president
uh and then we will have a a a changing
of the guard we will officially have it
trump will be out
biden will be in and we will go right
into
demanding that joe biden do the things
he promised to do on day one i'll give
him until day two i'll be honest i'll
i think day literally day one is tough
but maybe the first full day i expect
executive orders from joe biden on
thursday and we will be here with you
for everything so
we'll see you for that tomorrow we have
a great show today let me know if you'll
be watching i'm on twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the best and easiest way to support the
david pakman show is to grab
a membership at joinpackman.com
and you get lots of great stuff with it
as well
uh read all about it at joinpacman.com
we are
potentially minutes if not hours from
hearing
what is expected to be a list of 100
pardons from donald trump we don't know
as of this moment whether trump will try
to pardon himself
whether he will issue blanket preemptive
pardons for his children or son-in-law
or rudy giuliani at this moment
of recording and this may change within
an hour or within a couple of hours
we don't have that information we know
trump is expecting to pardon about a
hundred people today
however we have in the background an
insane story
alleging that rudy giuliani donald
trump's lawyer
i don't know if he's still technically
his lawyer it's never been clear uh it
hasn't been clear for months
rudy giuliani is being accused of
selling
pardons by trump for two million dollars
now the background on this
is that for some time we've heard
rumblings
of those who were collecting consulting
fees i guess you would call them
in order to lobby for a pardon from
donald trump
and now specifically rudy's name and the
cash figure
of two million dollars is being
associated with this uh
we know that there have been folks for
example who have said
listen um if you give me 50 grand
i'll try to get you a pardon and if i
succeed
you give me another 50 grand a one-time
top advisor
to the trump campaign reportedly
actually collected that 50 grand in
order to try to seek a pardon
for a guy named john kiriakou who's a
former cia
officer convicted of illegally
disclosing classified information
and kiriakou as he says it agreed to the
50 000
upfront fee and a 50 000 performance
bonus so
a 100 grand for a pardon not too bad 50
grand even if it fails okay that's i
guess the risk you're willing to take if
you're paying for pardons
but this is where the story gets very
interesting as reported by the new york
times mr kiriakou
who opted to go with the 50 down 50 if
we get it
uh payment plan was also offered uh
to pay two million dollars to rudy
giuliani
for what was claimed to be an
offer to secure a pardon so
sort of like you know you go to get a
car and you can trade in a car
or not and you can lease or you can
finance and if you lease you could do 24
or 36 months and
maybe you want 10 000 miles a year or 12
or 15.
there were pardon plans available you
could choose to do 50 down
50 if we get one that's one possibility
or you could go with someone
presumably believed to be closer to the
president rudy giuliani
who just wanted two million flat uh and
i guess was saying
you can definitely get the pardon this
way although there's never really a
guarantee of anything when donald trump
is involved and of course the immediate
question is could this possibly be legal
and um i i hate to say this but
it's not completely clear in the sense
that certainly a
president selling pardons would not be
legal
that that would be against the law now
whether you could prosecute a president
for it
that is certainly a question mark and
there are many people who say you can
and others who say it would be very
difficult
what we're talking about here can all be
couched under legal representation and
when rudy giuliani was confronted the
so the fbi was alerted rudy's selling
pardons for 2 million
and when rudy giuliani was confronted
about it rudy didn't say that's crazy
i don't know anything about two million
or anything like that i haven't talked
to anybody who wants a pardon
rudy giuliani's response was i challenge
the characterization of what it was i
was offering and that tells you
everything you need to know
i challenge the characterization
uh and and we'll even look at this key
part from the new york times
mr kiriakou was separately told that mr
trump's personal lawyer rudolph
giuliani could help him secure a pardon
for two million dollars
but mr kiriakou rejected the offer but
an associate fearing that mr giuliani
was illegally selling pardons alerted
the fbi
mr giuliani challenged this
characterization
that denial is barely a denial you're
challenging
the way it is characterized and what
obviously is going on here
is that legal services are being offered
i'm sure
that the way this is being framed is
rudy says listen
i offer legal services which include
representing
your request for a pardon between the
lines
it's i talk to trump every day and i
have influence over him and i feel
really strongly that i can make sure you
get a pardon but what i'm offering is
legal representation i will write the
letter i will represent you in any back
and forth
i will represent the pr and
public-facing part of this and i
estimate that my legal fee is going to
be two million dollars
and i take that as a retainer up front
is that illegal
no probably not i mean this is one of
those things where by the letter of the
law that's
probably not against the law and so
the move by rudy giuliani of course is i
challenge
the characterization it is insane
that this is what's going on and by the
time you listen to this we may know
who's on the pardon list
we're expected to know at some point
today we will certainly cover it for you
on tomorrow's program
the after the fact will be figuring out
who paid what for the pardons and again
technically it may be who paid for
consulting services
related to how to best ask for
a pardon i don't expect to see anybody
go down for selling pardons
because ultimately the only person who
can really sell the pardon is trump
himself
because he's the one doing the pardoning
i don't believe it's trump who's doing
it
it's clearly people around him uh it is
going to be a very very ugly
several years for the trump family
donald trump's organization is under
criminal investigation now on the eve of
donald trump
leaving office and i expect that january
21st
2021 meaning thursday is going to be a
fascinating day
for trump news trump is about to get
whacked
from 360 degrees with all sorts of
investigations
cnn reporting that the manhattan
district attorney's office
is expanding its criminal yet this is
criminal
investigation into the trump
organization's finances
it will include the family compound in
westchester
county prosecutors are interested in
this property called
seven springs because
it is related to many possible financial
crimes including
understating by dramatic amounts the
value of properties to save on taxes
while
inflating the value of those same
properties when they're used as
collateral for loans we've covered that
before
this investigation again it is a
criminal investigation
it also is drawing closer not just to
trump himself but to eric
trump not exactly known as the smart one
eric trump is the executive vice
president of the trump organization
he was directly involved in the apparent
riff raff related to this property
subpoenas are going out there are
uh requests for all sorts of files
emails correspondence and
this really is a threat to trump now i
want to be clear
this is not likely to put trump in
prison these are criminal investigations
into the organization
which would likely if taken to their
full conclusion
and if they find guilt they would lead
to
fines and potentially
criminal charges against lower level
people now
eric trump could count as a lower level
person here i don't expect to see eric
don jr or ivanka
locked up much like i don't expect to
see donald trump locked up we have to
have reasonable expectations
but this is something that is going to
grow and grow and grow
and remember that within 24 hours donald
trump will no longer have the shield of
the presidency
to delay lawsuits and investigations one
of the arguments that has been used by
donald trump's lawyers with some degree
of success
for the last four years even while trump
was was the nominee
the republican nominee back in 2016. one
of the arguments that trump lawyers have
used is
this would encumber donald trump's
ability to carry out his duties as
president of the united states
we have to put this off we have to put
this off we have to put this off but now
within 24 hours that's no longer going
to be an argument
and we have both criminal and civil
investigations happening related to the
seven springs property
and a whole bunch of other aspects of
the trump organization
we also are seeing the resumption of
sexual assault cases against donald
trump and while i maintain
i do not believe we will see a former
u.s
president in prison anytime soon and
that means
up to and including donald trump uh this
really could encumber trump for a very
long time i know there are some in my
audience who think
trump could end up in prison they are
waiting for the perp walk i don't think
we're going to see that
but the next couple of years are going
to be nuts regardless
prepare yourselves to be unable to keep
up with the legal fiasco
that is about to hit donald trump's
family it it's i look forward to trying
to keep up with it
but it will be really difficult to keep
up with all that the trump family is
about to get hit with the biggest
challenge right now facing prosecutors
is that there is so much possible
criminal behavior to
investigate that it will take years to
unravel they are going to have to break
it up into pieces
and different offices different squads
different investigative teams are going
to have to look at different elements of
it
and remember we still have money
laundering through the campaign there
are allegations
that close to i believe it was 160 or
170 million dollars
was effectively laundered these were
donations from trump supporters
meant to go to the campaign hundreds of
millions of dollars were reportedly
laundered through a company
controlled by trump's former campaign
manager brad parscale
and used to be funneled back to trump
family members
and to shell corporations with the doing
of jared kushner
that story alone like that has nothing
to do with the seven springs property
that has nothing to do with lies told
for tax benefits by the trump family
it that's a separate story the campaign
money laundering story
that one alone could take two years to
unravel so regardless of what comes of
it
this is going to be hell for the trump
family for years
the legal fees are going to explode
whether trump will pay them
is a question that remains open we
already know that even though rudy
giuliani
was billing 20 grand a day for his work
on trump's so-called election fraud
campaign
trump has said don't pay rudy so who
knows whether the lawyers will be paid
but millions of dollars in legal fees
will be billed and it is going to be a
wild couple of years
so i hope you'll be with us for it as
well as tomorrow for joe biden's
inauguration we'll be starting at 11 00
a.m eastern time live on youtube twitch
and facebook
you can also follow us on instagram
at david pakman show and follow me on
instagram at david.pack
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
since tomorrow joe biden will be
president of the united states we're
sort of closing the book on the trump
presidency today in a few different ways
and one such way is looking at approval
rating donald trump is leaving the white
house
with the lowest job approval of his
presidency which is 29
and yet it still seems so high
how could nearly a third of the people
in this country less than a third but
nearly a third of the people in this
country
think he's doing a good job still he's
been doing nothing for months
other than inciting that riotous
insurrection on january 6th
and it is true that trump voters
have grown more critical of trump
in his post-election conduct the share
of trump supporters
who describe his conduct as poor has
doubled over the last two months from 10
percent to 20 percent
a significant majority of americans
don't want trump trump to remain a major
political figure
after he leaves office about two-thirds
say
trump should be uh should evaporate as a
as a primary political figure of the
united states
joe biden is entering with 64
positive opinion which is great only in
the sense that it bodes well
and sets biden up well for the crucial
start of his presidency where we need
everybody on the same page in order to
finally get this pandemic under control
scale up vaccination and do the things
that have to be done
so those are all good signs but in term
of the in terms of the january 6th trump
riots
three-quarters of the public say that
trump bears
at least some responsibility for the
violence
and destruction committed by some of his
supporters
52 percent say trump bears a lot of
responsibility but we still have 24
percent
nearly a quarter of this country says
trump has zero responsibility for what
took place
that's extraordinarily weaponized this
information
and then maybe most disturbing a
majority of republicans
still think that donald trump actually
won the election
understand that 64 percent
of republican voters still believe as of
a few days ago when this survey was done
that it is actually donald trump who won
the election
two-thirds of republicans believe the
guy who's being sworn in tomorrow
did not really win and by the way
six percent of democrats also believe
trump won
i'd be interested in talking to some of
those folks that that's that's quite a
bit uh
that's just as depressing quite frankly
meanwhile
this is not the only data point from pew
in the gallup presidential approval
tracking poll trump also falling there
to a presidency low of 34
approval and i i have the same reaction
to both the 29
and 34 approval numbers 29 and 34
approval for trump are way too high
those numbers tell us that something is
very wrong with the country as if we
didn't already know but it confirms it
approval should be zero if only all of
this
had been completely predictable when
donald trump ran for president back in
2015. oh wait a second
it was completely predictable and we
were predicting that it would be this
bad
so there will be time for postmortems
but
it's still shocking and saddening
that there are people who thought
hillary would be the same as trump or
hillary would be as bad as trump or it
would make no difference to the to the
day-to-day
day-to-day lives of americans whether
it's trump or hillary
some people over the last year were
saying similar things about joe biden
joe biden would be
as bad as trump i hope no one is
listening to those people anymore
because they've given up their right to
be listened to i'm not saying they
shouldn't be allowed to speak
i'm not violating anyone suggesting
anyone's first amendment rights be
violated i'm just saying
at this point we have enough evidence to
realize
we shouldn't be listening to those
people by the way
there are also people who went from
voting for bernie
to voting for trump that also knowing
everything we know now is
extraordinarily disturbing it was
disturbing back in 2016
it's even more disturbing now because
everything has been so utterly
predictable
and yet some people are still acting
surprised so
good news trump's going out with the
lowest approval rating of his presidency
bad news nearly a third of the country
nearly a third of the country meaning
about
70 million people still
support the uh um
uh absolutely i'm sorry no
90 something million people my mouth was
wrong near something around 90 million
people still think trump is doing a good
job and that's going to be something
we'll have to deal with
for much much more time than trump is in
office which is fortunately
just a few more hours there are of
course hundreds of thousands dead now in
the united states from the coronavirus
and donald trump has been completely
silent about that
for months although he is absolutely
furious that so many celebrities are
going to be performing in the joe biden
inauguration
it is um immoral and inconceivable
that this is what trump is focused on
after his
failure that led to way more coronavirus
cases and deaths
than we needed to have trump is furious
that lady gaga will be performing for
joe biden
trump is furious that jennifer lopez and
tom hanks are going to be featured
at joe biden's inauguration tomorrow uh
donald trump is furious that country
singer garth brooks
who refused to participate in trump's
inauguration
although brooks said it was merely a
scheduling conflict
we'll be performing for joe biden
tomorrow now
garth brooks listen i don't know that
much about garth brooks's politics i
don't know if he's sort of like a dixie
chicks country artist
that is uh the rare uh progressive
exception
to what is a more conservative area of
music i don't know much about garth
brooks
i don't know that i believe it was
merely a scheduling conflict four years
ago
and that now he's doing it to unite the
country as he says maybe that's the case
maybe
scheduling conflict is just an excuse
but in any case
uh trump is furious and trump is furious
about the a-listers who shunned him
and he's furious that now they are going
to perform for joe biden
and i think that the story here really
is is uh
you know i don't really care about the
performances i think is the point
what i care about is the following it
appeared
during donald trump's campaign and it
was proven
during donald trump's presidency that
trump has only ever cared about himself
the riots are a perfect example trump
never cared about the rioters as
supporters i said this last week
when the rioters had the house and
senate cleared
and delayed the count of the electoral
votes trump was pleased
because that's what he wanted to see
happen when it became
clear that the rioters were appearing i
want to be careful in how i say it
trump's perception was that the writers
looked low class
trump was then mad he never cared about
the rioters when they were useful
and he never cared about the rioters
when they appeared low-class to him and
were making him look bad
and then when donald trump did that
speech saying all of the writers
will be and should be prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law
some people said oh he turned on his own
supporters no he didn't
he never cared about them as anything
other than
tools useful to him in achieving his
political goals that's it
full stop and so that's what this is
about
tragic numbers of coronavirus deaths at
last count
the u.s has surpassed 400 000
coronavirus deaths
and what donald trump cares about is how
is the joe biden inaugural going to look
relative to the trump inaugural
from the standpoint of celebrity
participants now
lucky for trump and i say this sort of
tongue-in-cheek who really cares about
this but
lucky for trump joe biden is not going
to have
a national mall filled with supporters
because of the virus
donald trump on day one of his
presidency
sent then press secretary sean spicer
out to lie about the size of trump's
crowds
trump's not going to be able to uh
trump's not going to have to fight about
that
because joe biden won't have a big crowd
because there's a pandemic and joe biden
is doing the responsible thing
but the lesson here is when it looked
like trump only cared about himself his
entire career
when it looked like trump only cared
about himself during his campaign
when it looked like trump only cared
about himself during his presidency
we were right that's exactly what it was
it's about gathering wealth
it's about inflating his ego and feeding
his pride
and something very interesting is about
to happen sociologically
to the trump family donald trump and
also his children
are about to realize how much everybody
really dislikes them
in the circles they used to run in when
he and they start to be
rejected from those very social circles
new york city
is not a cultural milieu that looks
forward to welcoming donald trump
they did accept him previously they're
not going to now and we've seen the new
york city signs saying no to jared and
ivanka
we've seen palm beach trying to stop
trump from doing the things he wants to
do
in moving back to mar-a-lago half the
country
is swearing off any of trump's hotels
for life
it is going to be a real awakening here
and of course donald trump is going to
blame others we know that
but it's still going to be something to
see now by the way
i don't care about how celebrity stuff
relates
to what's going on with trump biden uh
uh
beyond what it means for the culture of
the country
but the garth brooks thing really does
crack me up only because garth brooks
did
turn trump down in 2017 again saying it
was just a scheduling conflict
and now dr jill biden asked garth brooks
to play
and he said he's going to and he put out
a statement saying
this is merely a statement of unity this
is not a political statement i want the
country to be
united but trump very very triggered
and i can only imagine what is going to
happen as donald trump and his family
try to get back to uh to to normal life
and and remember
when you understand donald trump's goals
of uh placating his ego and and boosting
his self-importance
of being president and alienating half
the country and many of the business and
celebrity contacts that he previously
hung around with
uh it's going to be a real awakening and
i expect a very isolated trump and
the last thing on this and i want to
move on this goes back to when i was
talking about
trump only cares about his supporters as
useful political
tools and nothing else the people trump
has spent a life
wanting to associate with are the elites
in manhattan
uh powerful politicians global leaders
and
businessmen and this type of thing trump
has spent a life
trying to not be around the people that
are
the the vast majority of his voters and
so it's very interesting that as trump
leaves office
the only people that accept trump
are the people he spent a life trying
not to spend time around
really a a sociologically a very
interesting thing
so we'll be with you for the joe biden
inauguration starting tomorrow at 11am
eastern
i want to take a very brief break and
afterwards we're going to talk about
what will right-wing media look like for
the next two years we have a couple of
sort of
i guess i'll call them early signals
we're going to look at some interesting
clips they may be surprising they may
not
depending on how much attention you've
been paying
or did pay to what right-wing media
looked like under president barack obama
quick break
right back after this the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as
commercial-free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so i woke up this morning and reviewed
some of my preferred sources
for the sort of like what happened
yesterday in right wing
media and came across something that
made me wonder
did we perfect time travel have we
traveled back
to the time when barack obama was
president
because on fox news propagandist sean
hannity
wasted no he's not even waiting for joe
biden to be sworn in
he wasted no time he is already warning
about
concentration camps that the left is
going to set up
for trump supporters uh they did this
under barack obama conspiracy theorists
and others
talking about a forced internment camps
some of them use the term
fema camps some of them actually use the
term
concentration camps and now this is
remember in a year when this is has this
has exploded
that today i am playing for you what i
believe is the start
of the biden will put trumpists
in concentration camps meme this is the
2021 version of it
and they never change their conspiracy
theories
they just change who it is that's going
to do it to you
sean hannity saying they want to put
trumpists
in re-education camps take a look at
this
education camps deep programming okay
according to the press wing of the
democratic establishment party and the
socialist party
you we the people we need to be
deprogrammed or canceled or put in
re-education camps
because of our political opinion and it
differs from theirs
sadly after decades on tv and radio let
me just
tell you what this is really all about
now this effort
from the left it is not new it's only
accelerating
i'm not complaining but this has really
been my reality
now sean hannity is correct they do need
to be deprogrammed or reprogrammed
but a no serious leftist thinks putting
people in camps
is the way to deprogram uh trumpists i i
also like how he says
this is the dictate from the socialist
party what's
what socialist party there's no one in
power in the united states from the
socialist party
uh aoc claims to be a democratic
socialist and is really more of a social
democrat
what he's where where are these powerful
socialists hidden that they even have
influence in the united states that's
another red flag
that maybe sean hannity isn't actually
telling you the truth and
i i hate to tell you it pains me to tell
you this because it feels like we're
just rewinding back to 2015 2016.
um this stuff is going to go on for as
long as joe biden is president
the difference is you i i argue
that the difference about for example
concentration internment re-education
camp conspiracies in 2021 versus 2014
is that in 2014 way fewer people fell
for them
but the number of people that have
fallen for this q
anon wild trumpet stuff
tells us that there is a much larger
group of americans susceptible to it
today than there was during president
barack obama's presidency and that's
really scary
that's something that we i don't know
how we deal with that because
we've got newsmax and oan signal
boosting it
and um that you know you did you
occasionally had internment camps
fema camps mentioned on fox news during
obama's presidency
but this is going to be the bread and
butter of newsmax of oan
and and of others now if sean hannity by
re-education camp simply means we need
to fix schools
so that people come out of school better
able to think for themselves
not susceptible to the propaganda of fox
news
and of oan and of newsmax then listen
guilty is charged
i want to improve education that's for
sure i want to be teaching critical
thinking
i want to be teaching uh epistemology
call
guilty is charged if what the allegation
is is that we want to
better educate people but consider the
irony that they are the ones who have
been shouting lock them
up lock her up lock him up at rallies
for five years now
but the day before joe biden is sworn in
they go back to they're going to put
trumpists
in camps come on guys consider the irony
that they are the ones that came up with
and perpetuated
the war on drugs incarcerating uh
so many people for minor drug
infractions but they say
it's the left that wants to lock people
up in camps what
this doesn't even pass the sniff test
but as usual
with these people it's all projection
now one last thought
when we talk about radicalization and
what gets people to go out and try to do
real world violence
this is a perfect example beating people
over the head for months or years when
they want to put you in camps
they want to put you in camps because of
your political beliefs
this is what gets some people in their
audience some
to decide i'm going to go out and i'm
going to do something horrible
okay one very last thing i thought i was
on the last thing but i have one more
thing
you can only call it a re-education
camp if there's been education done
before
for a lot of these people they're just
lacking the education to begin with
around a lot of these issues including
how government works
how to think critically how to
understand and interpret media messages
for yourself so
for many folks the education problem is
so bad that there's no
re-education to do there's been no
education you say to people
how do you determine whether a message
you see on the news is true or false
i don't know i've never thought about it
i've never devoted it
nobody's ever given me a framework for
how to think about that so
this is a signal that much as we've been
predicting for months it's all going
back to the standard republican playbook
right-wing media projecting on to the
left the things that actually would be
better applied to them
pretending to care about the budget and
pretending to care about small
government and getting government out
obstruction of religious freedom first
amendment explosions
uh idiot they're going back to the
playbook so buckle up for some crazy
times
uh i was going to say we'll be covering
it once joe biden is sworn in but we're
covering it now
because they're wasting no time getting
started there are
a number of new members of the house of
representatives
who really should already resign or be
impeached
and at the very top of that list of that
list
is a congresswoman lauren bobert some
people are calling her
bobo the clown that we're not doing that
but there are people who are doing that
her name is lauren beaubert
she is one of the people who objected to
having to go through a metal detector to
get onto the house floor
she wants to be armed on the house floor
yada yada yada okay that's the person
i'm talking about and
allegations have been swirling that
she may have been complicit in the
riotous
pro-trump insurrection on january 6th
uh by having given tours
to the eventual radical insurrectionists
of the capitol building in the lead-up
to the january 6th riots now we already
heard for example
from congressman james clyburn who said
listen i have
a marked office and i also have an
unmarked office where i work as majority
whip or whip as frank underwood would
say
somehow they knew to go right to my
unmarked office that's weird
and on the other side of this puzzle are
the allegations that lauren bobert was
indeed
giving constituents tours of the capital
which
would be one way that the
insurrectionists would know exactly
where to go
she has denied it but democratic
congressman
steve cohen was interviewed about it and
says very clearly
he saw lauren beaubert leading a large
group
through the capital in the days before
the riots
he can't say these were the
insurrectionists he's not at a point
where he can say that
but it would at least directly
contradict lauren bobert's claim
that she did no such thing let's take a
look at the video
that's remarkable remarkable to hear i
want to ask you about something specific
because several of your colleagues have
alleged that the rioters
may have received inside help including
including raising the prospect of tours
conducted or with the okay of fellow
sitting members of congress this is
quite a charge to make
have you seen any hard evidence to
substantiate that allegation only thing
that i've seen
at congressman yarmouth refreshed my
recollection yesterday
we saw congressman bobert uh taking a
group of people for a tour
sometime after the third and before the
sixth i don't remember the day we were
walking
in a bottle we saw her and commented
that
she was and she had a large group of
women now whether
they were people that they're all uh
you know
people coming to be with her on this
historic occasion and just wanting to
give them the opportunity to have a tour
but it's pretty clear that her team is
is the team she's not on the home team
she was with the visitors
so lauren beaubert is denying this and
there's a few different things here that
might be going on because
there's cameras everywhere there's guest
books
there it is certainly knowable whether
lauren bobert was leading a crowd of
people whether it was an official tour
or something else around the capitol
this is information authorities are able
to get so why hasn't anyone come out and
said
we have the video she did do it or we've
reviewed
she didn't do it excuse me one idea
is that the feds much like they often do
are waiting for her to
make specific claims that are lies
before they present her with the
evidence to the contrary
there's maybe a political aspect to it
one idea i got an email from someone
saying you know maybe the feds
are waiting to release the evidence that
lauren beaubert did this
for the inauguration simply to prevent
any even
minute possibility that trump would
think
to pardon her uh maybe they're waiting
for the evidence to pile up and for her
to lie about it
but there is uh no
doubt that it is knowable whether lauren
bobert and other members of congress
were giving tours through the capitol
and by the way
if it's all recorded it's probably
knowable whether the people that she was
allegedly giving a tour to
were later involved in the january 6th
riots
so for a ton of this stuff just in
general
these questions apply to the trump
family investigations as well
it makes some sense to wait until after
the inauguration to really scale up the
investigations into trump organization
criminal and financial
wrongdoing uh just so that donald
trump's presidential power is over
um i i as i said earlier we are going to
see the trump family hit with many
investigations as well
but this needs to be figured out lauren
bobert's office did not immediately
respond to questions from talking points
memo
about you know she denies that there was
a tour
but steve cohen says he saw her doing it
how could both be true do you have a
comment no comment so far
but if we're looking for any signal
about what may be to come
lauren beaubert's communications
director
has already quit now i know you're
saying she's been in office a few days
what do you mean
yes lauren bobert's communications
director has already quit
now in terms of the broader issue of
some of these wacky new
members of congress um we've got lauren
bobert
we have marjorie taylor green i call her
q a non-congresswoman
there's this guy madison cawthorne who
has talked about
having multiple firearms on him on his
wheelchair
when he's on the floor of the house of
representatives this is a very bad
direction for the country to be going in
and my instinct is when it comes to
bobert versus marjorie taylor greene
i want you to gut check me on this and i
tweeted about this over the weekend
when i see lauren bober i see someone
who is more of an opportunist and who
may go
too far and end up in prison or expelled
from congress for her antics
but i see her more as a calculated
opportunist
marjorie taylor green i see is an actual
committed q a nut who really has drank
the kool-aid
and i could see her either as a cult
member or even a cult leader although
she doesn't necessarily seem smart
enough to be a cult leader and it
doesn't seem
manipulative enough to be a cult leader
but that's where i see the difference
between lauren beaubert and marjorie
taylor green
let me know your thoughts i'm curious to
see where you fall on this
okay we have a voicemail number 219
to david p you can call it any time of
day
here's a caller who believes i'm a liar
and this is a double whammy david's a
liar and
the show is playing in the background
this is a classic where
they can't even be bothered to pause the
show
so i hear my own voice in the background
as they leave the voicemail this is a
a classic as old as time itself take a
listen
oh my gosh
what do you mean he didn't do nothing
for the violence
give me a friggin break you never cared
about the writers you're crazy
and you're telling you're lying to your
teeth
right now giving me a little bit of
credit
yeah you guys just don't know
there's nothing that who yours
yeah so that's pretty interesting and i
have to tell you for the howard stern
fans in the audience i know it can't be
because sadly
we we uh we we lost eric the actor
years ago but that is a dead ringer for
for eric the actor a frequent uh former
frequent regular caller
to the howard stern show so very
interesting stuff and again i don't
i've never gotten an explanation as to
why they can't pause the show
to leave their screeds on my voicemail
but you can call if you want to send me
a message
2192 davidp real quick
very exciting our good friend
jay tomlinson host of the best of the
left podcast
has just published his 15th anniversary
episode
huge okay you go to best of the left dot
com slash
listen best of the left dot com
slash listen best of the left is
an actual award-winning podcast the
david pakman shows an award-winning
podcast but we've only won awards we
give out
you know so which makes them less
credible jay's best of the left has
actually won awards administered by
someone other than himself
and if you're not familiar with this
show every episode is a deep dive into a
political or cultural topic
you hear clips from a variety of shows
then you also hear
jay's analysis and commentary so 15-year
anniversary for best of the left
great friends of the david pakman show
go to best of the left dot com
slash listen to check it out and the
bonus show doesn't speaking of aw
speaking of award-winning from awards we
give out
the bonus show doesn't stop rudy
giuliani will not represent trump at his
impeachment trial and i will tell you
why and it's pretty funny
parlor has partially come back to life
with the support of a russian technology
firm i know i know
and uh we will talk about a future trump
presidential library uh and whether
trump would prefer a theme park rather
than a library
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show uh get access
instantly by becoming a member at
joinpackman.com
coupon code better21 saves you
massive amounts off of a membership and
lastly
join us tomorrow for the inauguration
11am eastern
8 a.m pacific we will start with the
inauguration of joe biden to the
presidency of the united states
don't miss it youtube twitch and
facebook
i will see everybody then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
slash david pakman steady md lets you
maintain a meaningful long lasting
relationship with a primary care
physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99 dollars a month with
no other fees or copays visit
steadymd.com
pacman to get started